hello friends i'm alana and welcome to
my channel
just a quick video for your monday
evening i made a video i don't know
maybe a month ago
about game reviews and what it was like
reviewing games at ign
and sort of addressed some common
criticisms people have
of game reviews and a lot of
misconceptions
and there have been a bunch of comments
in response to that
where people say i stopped reading ign
as soon as too much water happened
a lot of these people are just memeing
because it is a very easy thing to make
fun of
it is clearly not a well-written phrase
that's like
half the problem but i do also think
a lot of the comments that sort of
elaborate on why they don't like too
much water or that are being serious
about it
are just kind of dunking on themselves
for not having read the review
so i'm making this video um inspired by
one particular comment let me read it
for you this says
i stopped reading ign when too much
water happened what a dumb thing to say
they don't understand that just walking
around on land all the time is boring
and a map with water is way more fun
like gta for example
again have seen a lot of comments of
people criticizing too much water
um who just definitely don't know what
it means because it's actually
a very good criticism freeze very poorly
which you are absolutely allowed to make
fun of ign for for the record i didn't
work
at ign when this happened i did write
a blog post about how i felt like
everyone was missing the legitimate
point though
so if we go through this review i wonder
if it's still at the bottom
it looks like it's gone
yeah i think because ign actually got
rid of their um
pros and cons which i imagine probably
happened in some part because of
this issue uh too much water is no
longer listed
if i just make myself a little bit
smaller there we go
so this is really for anyone who is
curious or like you know
if because a lot of people seem to have
missed the point this is like for if you
want to know i'm totally not
even trying to defend it i'm just trying
to expand on the thing because a lot of
people have clearly misunderstood it
if you would prefer to not be informed
uh because it might ruin the joke
a little bit for you then leave now
so there is nothing in this review that
says oh there's too much water on the
map
i don't like water ocean's bad no it's
specifically listed here it says it's
not a new complaint but hoenn is still
unbalanced
typewise heavily favoring water it's
especially noticeable in alpha sapphire
and which team aqua the villains of
the piece use a lot of water types it
feels like there are water pokemon in
nearly every battle and i have an
overleveled pikachu
pikachu to show for it you also have to
navigate many bodies of water since much
of the late game involves
the hm surf and dive to get from place
to place
this paragraph which again is a solid
criticism
uh was basically just minimized into the
phrase too much water which
sounds so silly and i think you know
ign is right to have removed the pros
and cons list because a lot of people
just read them without reading the
review and i guess they didn't think
about it that way
they were like no it just summarizes
everything we said in the review but it
totally didn't work that way because
people would just skip the review and
read the thing
what it's saying is that because there
are
so many villains that have water type
pokemon and so many areas where you are
on water
you literally have to change your team
to have electric type pokemon in order
to counter the amount of water pokemon
that you fight
which again i think is a solid criticism
and very fair because one of my favorite
things about playing pokemon games
in my opinion is uh the fact that your
team can be so customized
that statistically it wouldn't be
unreasonable for me to guess that
you have never had the same team that i
have had and when you are specifically
playing one of the only pokemon games
that
just constantly gives you water type
pokemon to fight
it means that your team isn't
necessarily just the same well-rounded
team that you would always like to have
it takes away some of your choice by
forcing you to build up a team that is
good
against water type pokemon which means
you don't necessarily have all the
pokemon that you love i think it just
especially you know
for an rpg series it is for sure a flaw
that in order to succeed you have to
cater to
one specific enemy type and it's like
just also very limiting when there are
so many
kinds of enemy types in uh in pokemon
that you would restrict me to just
finding water that's what uh that's what
too much water means
there are literally too many water
pokemon which means that
most fights are going to be the same and
require the same
special attacks and involve having
a team of electric pokemon who are very
leveled up it's legitimately like a
completely solid criticism like that is
i agree with the flaw obviously
where ign went wrong here was thinking
everyone would read
the review and then immediately know
what the pros and cons mean
and even outside of that i think that's
giving them too much credit it's it's
such a silly way to phrase that
from my understanding the person who
wrote the review wasn't actually the one
who wrote
the con someone else put that in it
originally said type imbalance but they
were like oh that sounds too complicated
so they changed it to too much water
which is so silly and so memeable um i'm
absolutely not defending any of that
side of it it is
it is very silly but also just you know
yeah i wanted to make this quick video
to explain literally what it means in
case there are people who've ever been
curious about what it
actually is referring to or maybe wanted
the information
if you have clicked on this because you
enjoy the meme i'm not trying to take
that away from you
as you were and that is pretty much all
i have to say i will
i will see you guys next time bye